Netflix in the early days we're talking
with the late 90s was terrified that was
going to go out of business
they were they were mailing DVDs and it
was very expensive to do that so they
weren't making any money and blockbuster
was this Colossus and so Reed Hastings
the founder of Netflix gets on an
airplane goes to Dallas to try and
convince Blockbuster to come together
and partner in some way ultimately what
he really wanted was for Blockbuster to
buy Netflix and finet flicks to be there
long range online arm because he knew
one day he would be delivering
television over or video over the
Internet and blockbuster could have its
stores but he thought the stores would
be in decline as in fact happened
Blockbuster in retrospect stupidly
declined to to invest in Netflix and
within a couple of years Netflix had had
basically helped destroy Blockbuster
blockbuster was an old technology you
went to a video store to rent a video
most of the top 20 movies were already
out of stock because people had rented
them so there's a lot of frustration and
Netflix was basically you know get what
you want when you want it and and knew
that they would move away from the DVD
business to a download video business so
you wouldn't you could watch as many you
know you could never run out of stock I
I think it's very accurate to compare
Netflix to a book and I think that's
part of the forward vision that Hastings
had if you think about the way what
Netflix has done with what what has come
to be called binging it basically
replicates a book because it basically
says you want to watch house of cards or
orange is the new black you don't have
to wait and watch it at 10 o'clock on
Friday nights or 8 o'clock on Thursday
nights you can watch it whenever you
want and by the way you don't have to
watch commercials
and by the way which means the show is
longer and by the way you don't have to
watch a single episode you can watch
multiple episodes watch as long as you
want eat as much as you want just as
when you read a book you want to read
more than one chapter you read more than
one chapter so the analogy is is is apt
and I think he was smart about that
blockbuster had their resources
and had it been smart enough to go
online invest some of those resources to
go online they would have decimated
Netflix blockbuster was you know its
ownership didn't want to spend the money
they were engaged in battles with Carl
Icahn a potential takeover effort on his
part and and they suffered the classic
innovators dilemma which was they
basically said we have a good existing
business with these thousands of video
stores why should we disrupt it with for
a maybe business the online world that
may never pan out and and let's stick to
the net keep to the Knitting and that's
what they did and they they lost their
name
you